Hallo, das ist Robert, wir haben später ein
Problem, das
in China hergestellt wurde und jetzt besser ist als in
Deutschland hergestellt. Sie glauben, es war nicht unser letzter
Effendon, als wir die Auto-
Finster-Jagdkonsole auf leitfähig umstellten und unsere gesamte
Energie von Putin mitbrachten und
nur noch exportierten  Gazetten, alle
Ratschläge sind jetzt im Arsch, wir sind Verlierer,
ein Garbo ihm und Mantel, keine Medaillen im
Laufen und Springen, Fußball-VM, im
Vordergrund, sogar unsere Frauen spielen wie Männer.
Deutschland ist wirklich nicht mehr das Gelbe
vom Ei, also kommt
bitte und kommt  Arbeite für uns, bitte,
bitte. Ich bitte dich, nach Deutschland zu kommen, aber nicht
mit dem deutschen Dutt.
[Applaus]